wouldn't it be great if you didn't have
to worry about hiding your gifts anymore
hi I'm Jubilee and it wasn't that long
ago when I felt that way too but then I
became a student at Xavier school for
gifted youngsters and everything changed
so Tony we've both seen Xmen apocalypse
now and we're about to spoil the hell
out of it and stay away from this video
if you don't want to know the ending and
all the stuff in between Xmen apocalypse
but before we get into that you like the
movie right I liked it I didn't love it
I didn't hate it I mean there is a lot
of good moments there's some cool
moments I felt it was a really ambitious
movie they tried upping the game the
threat the aspect of story from the
previous but there's also a lot that was
crammed in that made parts of it fall a
little flat and yeah it's that ambition
that you think sort of held it down a
little bit right so and there's a few
sort of key moments in the film that
kind of stood out for both of us right
and I guess one of the first ones there
is isn't the whole more thing so explain
to me what your what your issue is with
more in a bill yeah so so here you have
a character you know in first class she
got her memory wiped Professor X goes to
her and then that's where she informs
them on the history of who is this
apocalypse character they call
themselves a sheer n seven year named
after an ancient being they believed to
be the world's first world's first what
the world's first mutant actually it
doesn't really make sense in the movie
in the comics he's cut at different
points in history he's been seen as a
god but in a movie he would have been
buried alive all this time unless those
stuff that happened before but Eddie's
it was cool as sheep she brings it up
touches on stuff in the Bible and all
that so you get kind of a sense of who
he is is he this creature that cause all
these different myths or stories and
stuff like that but it was as good they
brought her in to kind of anchor that
the feeling otherwise how's professor x
know who this dude is like my biggest
problem with maura in this film was she
was essentially the person that set the
whole thing into motion by accidentally
like leaving that space for sunlight to
actually
he'll apocalypse and reactivate his
powers they could've just days of future
past her and like going back in time
stop more from doing that and save
themselves the whole hassle of I'm
assuming a lot of people died in this
film they don't actually see because a
published just ruins the earth and
magneto actually would answer like many
in many ways so that's what really
bugged me of that more now you bring it
up Moira's kind of a jerk it's all her
fault the whole thing is you know she
doesn't have her memories from before
but then as Professor X is wounded he's
almost dying he gives her memories back
and then she's like oh he's like I'm
sorry I'm sorry for tampering with your
mind and making you forget everything at
the total dick movie but Professor X and
she just forgave me when I I thought she
would like slap him or somebody it's
like he was dying ok we're gonna move on
for more and now she was problematic
yeah but should we have a problem with
the movies we get some reintroduction to
characters so I like angel and
Nightcrawler for example they are both
in the second x-men movie de riginal x2
we see them in the cage match
so this is ten years after days of
future past mutants are kind of accepted
but there's still kind of feared so
there's this weird it was an underground
Fight Club yeah and it's like they were
being forced to fight you know it's a
they didn't have a choice so you kind of
wonder what where did they what I do
when they're not fighting you know are
they locked in the cell so that wasn't
really clear to me but we see them again
and one of the problems which leads into
the four horsemen you know like like we
see angel his wings get damaged and then
after that he can't really use his wings
anymore apocalypse finds him I'll give
you new metal wings and that was it so
there was there was even an exchange
it's just like boom he's he's bad he's
gonna destroy the world yeah I think
just generally the motivations for most
of the horsemen weren't really explain
no no it seemed to me that apocalypse
actually controlled the mind of storm
but just convinced the other three like
hey you should totally you know help me
out or whatever purposes that decided to
because the storm it wasn't really clear
cuz she she kind of idolized mystique
mr. chisam mystique as this
inspirational mutant you know she took
the stand 10 years before and then she
finds apocalypse she doesn't really know
who he is offers him a coke and then he
does some stuff to returns her hair
white which is kind of weird because one
of the things apocalypse it he would
like unlock their full potential powered
them up amp them up but for some reason
that made her hair turn white and then
she's gonna do his evil bidding and then
with sila she had her psychic dagger and
then he's like I'll give you more power
and it's a sword and she's like okay so
like with her I mean she was Elise you
explain there is no motivation
whatsoever and she just completely just
walks away at the end of the film is
like there's a shot of a sort of like
walking out of frame and then that's it
cuz at least with storm you noted that
she's like okay this guy was a big jerk
he was wrong I'm gonna hang out with the
good guys now but with cylot you you
don't know what she's gonna do so
hopefully that will be addressed in
another movie how about magneto Oh
magneto Michael Fassbender he had such a
tragic story yes
so you within a 10 years he finds a new
life has a wife has a kid a daughter
she's a mutant living this quiet life
working in the factory no knows who he
is until he saves a guy he's outed
tragic things happened his parents and
then he's just gonna screw you guys it's
like you guys were at church he goes
full-on he'll mode yeah again for a
little bit new rope degil my name isn't
Henrik
my name is Magneto do you think it was
natural how he went back to the side of
good at the end could you see that or
was that to start on a ship for you
because I felt a little sudden for me
Magneto's always kind of straddle the
line between you know good and bad he's
been focused on mutant rights and all
that that's been his main thing but the
interesting thing with what the other
three horsemen apocalypse kind of turned
them he did that you know son lock their
full potential he didn't do that with
magneto he just kind of guided him but
he never liked touched him or did
anything like that so it's almost as if
he took advantage of Magneto's emotions
you know being so distraught that got
him to turn on his side but he didn't
have to amp power him up because he is
already so powerful that you know you'd
have to do that so I mean if you're a
fan of movies you know it's it's not a
horrible movie it's not like ruining the
franchise it's not destroying everything
there are a lot of cool scenes cool
stuff happening it's just there's a lot
in going into it don't have high
expectations don't think it's like going
to be the best you know comic book movie
of all for me this was the the least of
the new trilogy that they've done so I
still rate first class and then days of
future past and then this one in and out